- [Voiceover] We are asked to
draw the line of reflection
that will map quadrilateral SORT,
S-O-R-T
onto the other quadrilateral below.
So this is the other
quadrilateral right over here.
So we wanna reflect SORT
so it maps onto this other quadrilateral,
and we wanna draw or define
the line of reflection using
this tool right over here.
And so see if I just kind of eyeball it,
it looks like, it looks like something,
something like, that is
starting to get close
but not quite.
And the way I could tackle this,
I could look at corresponding points.
I could say look, point S right over here
in the image after the reflection
the corresponding point
is that right over there.
And so the line of reflection
should contain a point
that is half way between these two points.
And so what's a point
that's halfway between them?
Well, let's see, where I have
it right now isn't halfway.
If I put it there, that
actually looks halfway
between this point and the
corresponding point in the image.
Notice, to get from here to there,
I took one to the left,
I had to take one step to
the left, three steps up
to go from here to here,
I take one step to the
left, three steps up.
So these are definitely the same distance
away from this point and this point,
are both the same distance
away from this line
or this point that's on this line.
So now let's see where
this point could go,
and I could do something similar.
I could try to find,
let's see, I need to
find a different point.
Let's see, maybe a point that's halfway
between this point and T
and the corresponding point of the image
which is that over there.
And let's see, I can probably put it,
that actually looks pretty good
because this is one step to the left,
three steps up, and then
to get from here to there,
one step to the left and three steps up.
So this looks pretty good.
This looks like I have drawn
the line of reflection.
This point that I'm
highlighting right now in orange
is halfway between T and
the corresponding point
to the image.
This point right over here is halfway
between S and the corresponding
point of the image.
You need to just to have two points
to define our line, this looks like
my line of reflection.
Let's see whether I'd got it right.
And I did.